ces trois lettres provoque la colère de
nombreux martiniquais les vhs gangrène
nos paysages depuis longtemps ce matin
le procureur a envoyé un signal fort en
direction des garagistes une opération
d'enlèvement a été lancé dans le cadre
du comité opérationnel de lutte contre
la délinquance environnementale la
police municipale du gros morne et la
gendarmerie étaient à la manoeuvre et à
trois garages qui sont concernés ain et
en plus ce garagiste se trouve le à côté
de l'autre dans la même
dans la même route est là actuellement
on l'a déjà enlevé
une dizaine de véhicules vh et voilà et
c'est ce véhicule
iront en fourrière bien entendu un les
propriétaires de véhicules emmenaient en
fourrière seront mises en demeure de les
récupérer sous 10 jours
au delà ils seront passibles d'une
amende et les voitures seront détruites
pour les véhicules hors d'usagé la
procédure est différente
les responsabilités sont à rechercher
les concessionnaires avance les frais
c'est vrai qu'on n'arrive pas à
retrouver l'ensemble des propriétaires
de ces véhicules
donc en bout de chaîne ce sont bien
l'association de t d avait haché dont
qui va financer ses opérations là par
contre si on arrive à retrouver le
propriétaire dans ces cas là c'est lui
qui va financer l'opération l'an dernier
1700 vhs ont été collectées sur les
20000 qui polluent la martinique
l'objectif pour 2019 et de ramasser au
moins 5000 véhicules hors d'usagé
particuliers et professionnels sont
prévenus
la lutte contre les vhs accélère